the rhinoceros
it's got its own bodyguards
and its skin sweats blood
but you won't believe what gives the
rhinos horn its point it's one of the
fastest healing structures that we know
of then
the tiger
it has fangs that can feel
and there are secret messages in its
stripes
plus they're perfectly designed to turn
meat
into pure muscle
i mean people are scared of bears
bears are scared of tigers
and find out where it's illegal for two
pigs to copulate
where you can't push a moose from an
airplane
and what you can't do with your donkey
in arizona
that is the weirdest law
[Music]
this is where savage meets science
and wild becomes
wow
[Music]
this is everything you didn't know about
animals
it's over 2 000 pounds heavier than a
military-grade hummer
yet still faster than usain bolt
and there's a secret in its horn that
makes it tougher than the sun
it's built like a tank
sometimes acts like a puppy
and it was once the biggest mammal to
ever walk the earth
it's
the rhinoceros
the rhinoceros is the second biggest
land mammal next to the elephant
but the impressive secrets it hides are
second to none
they seem to be an enigma in a lot of
ways a lot of the things that appear to
be the case in rhinos are not
necessarily the case when you learn
about them
to prove it we're examining the most
surprising ways in which the rhinoceros
is not what it seems
starting at the beginning of the rhino's
face
the whole point of this animal
its horn
the rhinoceros is the only mammal alive
that has a horn
on its nose
because of the black market trade
rhinoceros horn is one of the most
expensive materials on earth
more valuable than cocaine heroin gold
or even platinum
[Music]
but what makes this sphere so special
it's not like it's the only horn around
from antelope
to zebus
a lot of animals have horns
and for a lot of different reasons
but the one thing almost all of them
have in common is a strong core made of
solid bone
not so with the rhinoceros
rhinos do something different
in that what they do is rather than have
a bony horn core they build the entire
thing out of keratin
the same material that we have in our
fingernails and in our hair
the horn is made up of soft tubules of
keratin proteins that interweave to
create a hard keratin matrix
it's more close in consistency to a
horse's hoof
or a sea turtle's beak than a bull's
bony horns
believe it or not one of the only other
known examples of an animal growing a
horn out of mostly keratin
is in humans
because of a rare skin disorder a french
woman named madame dimanche once grew a
nearly 10 inch keratin horn on her
forehead
for some reason she waited six years to
have it removed
the biggest rhino horn on record was
nearly five feet long
which would almost be like carrying
around one full-grown mary kate or
ashley olsen
in fact a rhino's horn never stops
growing
and the horn hides another secret that
not only gives it its shape but helps
make it strong enough to take on the sun
[Music]
in the deserts and savannahs where
rhinos roam the sun can be as tough as
any predator
our skin and our keratinized structures
are very sensitive to uv light
and so is the rhinos horn
but only recently professor lawrence
whitmer used ct scanners
to reveal something inside the horn
that makes it tough enough to stand up
to the elements
so what i've got here is actually the
the back horn from a white rhino
this is really interesting this was
completely unexpected it never been
described before and this dark band is
actually formed of the pigment called
melanin
melanin the same dark pigment that gives
us humans our tans and what's
interesting about melanin is that it's
resistant to the ultraviolet rays that
come from the sun
so even if the sun wears away the soft
outer layers of keratin the tough
melanin core keeps the horn intact and
gives it its pointed shape
[Music]
it kind of looks like a cross between an
elephant and a hippo
but that's just another way the
rhinoceros is not what it seems
the truth is it's more closely related
to zebras and horses and the way you can
tell
is by looking at the toes
[Music]
these are animals that have an odd
number of toes
so we sometimes refer to
this group as being what we call
odd-towed ungulates
the foot makeup if you saw the skeleton
looks quite like a horse's foot
and just like with the horse that odd
number of toes makes the rhino
surprisingly light on its feet
a team of veterinarians in the united
kingdom have been studying rhinoceros
locomotion
and they found that even though rhinos
can weigh up to four tons walking on
three toes each toe only feels a peak
pressure of around 75 pounds per square
inch
[Music]
to put that in perspective
when a 110 pound ballerina is on point
she's feeling a whopping 583 pounds of
pressure per square inch on her toes
so a rhino is actually feeling 508 fewer
pounds per square inch on its toes than
a ballerina
rhino swan link anyone
[Music]
the great thespian ethel barrymore great
aunt of drew barrymore once said for an
actress to be a success she must have
the face of venus the figure of juno and
the hide of a rhinoceros
her point you gotta have thick skin
and at up to two inches the rhinoceros
has some of the thickest in the animal
kingdom
a full inch thicker than an elephant's
but in the wild no armor can withstand
all blows
that's why a rhino skin has an amazing
back-up plan
rhino skin is one of the fastest healing
structures that we know of and
scientists have been studying it trying
to wonder why they heal so well
if you see a rhino fighting together
and they get scratches all over their
face
[Music]
the next day
it almost completely healed i mean it's
amazing
this amazing ability may have something
to do with the makeup of the skin itself
layer upon layer of thick criss-crossing
collagen fibers arranged in a lattice
structure
which as it turns out may provide the
perfect scaffolding for new cell growth
scientists in china are already using
collagen extracted from tilapia skin to
accelerate wound healing in lab rats
but there's an even bigger secret hiding
behind that amazing skin
one almost unheard of in the wild
they sweat blood
i'm not
kidding
when rhinos sweat they have kind of a
red tinge sweat and if you look at it
under the microscope you see red blood
cells
why is that
why do rhinos have red blood cells in
their sweat nobody knows
it's fascinating
[Music]
the white rhinos head alone can weigh up
to 1 000 pounds as much as two
full-grown lions
but what's hiding out inside that head
may be one of the most misunderstood
parts of the rhino yet
can you guess the surprising weight of a
rhino's brain
is it a as heavy as a croquet ball
b as heavy as a bowling ball
or c as heavy as a medicine ball
[Music]
the rhinoceros
its head alone can weigh up to 1 000
pounds
but before the break we asked you to
guess the surprising weight of the brain
inside
is it a as heavy as a croquet ball
b as heavy as a bowling ball
or c as heavy as a medicine ball
the answer is
a
only as heavy as a croquet ball
[Music]
when we look at the brain and the brain
cavity of rhinos
it's pretty small
[Music]
the frame can be maybe not more in a
pound for an animal that can be eight
thousand pounds
that's a body to brain ratio of eight
thousand to one
if humans have that same ratio our three
pound brains weigh just 10 grams about
as light
as four pennies
[Music]
a group of rhinos is called a crash
no one knows why
but before two solo rhinos can make a
crash they have to meet each other and
while modern man often uses social media
to hook up
the rhinoceros has a much lower tech
solution
their profiles are in their poop
[Music]
rhinos defecate every day and they
usually defecate in what's called a
midden it's basically a spot dedicated
to where they defecate
and the average rhino can drop 50 pounds
of dung every 24 hours as much as a
whole bale of hay
but they're not just leaving behind
waste
they're also placing secret chemical
cues other rhinos can smell to gather
intel about the owner
we can almost view these dung heaps as
sort of being like their own little
twitter feed or facebook profile where
they've actually got um information
about themselves that are in these dump
piles now they can tell if it's a young
rhino or an old rhino or a male from a
female or if the female is in estrus or
not ready to breed
[Music]
and so these rhinos will be looking at
other dung heaps and getting information
about their social network
and if another rhino wants to leave the
owner a message he just adds to the pile
the equivalent of posting to someone's
wall
over time some of these mittens can
reach three feet tall and 16 feet across
as wide and almost as high as an
above-ground pool
smelling these piles a rhino can do
everything from finding a mate
to avoiding fatal encounters
so in a very real way the survival of
the species depends on smelling poop
with massive nasal passages
and an olfactory system that takes up
the majority of the brain
a rhino's sense of smell is among the
strongest in the animal kingdom
animals like rhinos live in a different
world it's a world of odors that we
don't really understand
but then the rhino had to develop a
strong sense of smell
because when it comes to its eyes
things are much less acute
[Music]
they can only see if you know a couple
hundred yards and even then not very
clearly in fact if the object isn't
moving and can't be smelled the rhino
may not be able to differentiate it from
a tree but they're not flying completely
blind
they've got some help they've got sort
of an onboard sensory system which are
these birds that tend to hang around
with with rhinos in swahili they're
called the rhinos guard
their scientific name is the oxpeckers
the rhino calls them both their eyes in
the sky
and onboard parasite control
they're eating ticks and bugs and
helping keep the rhino skin clean but
when their predator comes around they
start squawking and flying
they're the ones who alert the rhino
quite like a car alarm will alert you
that someone's stealing your car that
means predators rarely have a chance to
get the jump on a rhino it's also why
there's no such thing as grand theft
rhino
[Music]
the rhinoceros has a reputation for
being big and aggressive
but is everything as it seems
easy
one unsuspecting tourist in africa is
about to find out
[Music]
krueger national park
a tourist finds the road blocked by an
aggressive white rhino
he tries to go around slowly but then
the animal
the frightened charges
just barely gets away but not before a
hard slam from the raging beast at least
it looked like it was raging but what's
really going on here
and are rhinos really the aggressive
animals they appear to be
they can be unpredictable and
particularly if you get between
a rhino and its baby
but in all other circumstances they have
no desire to hurt you
i mean they're herbivores they don't eat
meat
in fact some rhinos are more playful
puppy than raging ball
the rhinos actually liked human touch
and they love being scratched behind
their ears under their eyes and around
their mouth they're very gentle that way
and rhino skin parts of it are very very
soft like the part inside
the lower leg where you rub or on the
abdomen or under the eye these folds
under the eyes it's like petting velvet
i mean it's just amazing so who knows
that charging rhino might just be coming
in for a rub
today there are five species of
rhinoceros alive on earth
the black the white the indian the javin
and the sumatran which is the closest
living relative of the extinct woolly
rhino but 30 million years ago 35
million years after the age of dinosaurs
rhinos were much more varied ranging in
size from your average german shepherd
to this its name is paraceratherium and
unlike modern rhinos it didn't have a
horn it didn't need one because this
beast did and still does hold the title
of biggest mammal ever to walk the earth
this rhino stood more than 20 feet so
they stood higher than two school buses
they weighed an estimated 20 to 25 tons
which is about the size of four bull
elephants
now rhinos are among the most endangered
animals on the planet
but if current conservation efforts
succeed
millions of years in the future the
rhinoceros might look very different
than it does now
[Music]
i mean who knows maybe there'll be
several hundred species like there used
to be
if it gets a little colder we might see
the resurgence of something that we had
10 12 15 million years ago which was the
woolly rhino
and maybe they'll be hornless forms and
giant rhinos like giraffe that are
feeding off the trees in california or
new york it's hard to say what rhinos
will look like in the future
hopefully still a little something like
this the rhinoceros may be one of the
biggest
[Music]
but size isn't everything
and some of the most powerful animals on
the planet
[Music]
are no bigger than a baseball
these are our top three most amazing
small wonders
[Music]
number three is on the list because it
may provide a link to understanding how
alcohol consumption
started in humans
it's the pen tailed tree shrew
this rarely seen shrew chronically
consumes fermented nectar
and at any given second has a blood
alcohol level that could kill people
it's the equivalent to a human drinking
12 glasses of wine
in under two hours
i i would be on the ground
[Music]
number two on our countdown of small
time heavy hitters puts even the most
macho man to shame it's the honey possum
it's just half the size of a mouse but
it has in relation to the size of its
body
[Music]
the biggest testicles of any animal on
earth
if humans had testicles that size i mean
they literally would have water melons
in their pants
[Music]
but few animals are as amazing as our
number one small wonder in fact
if you can get past the freak factor
you'll find an animal so powerful it
could make life more livable for humans
it's
the naked mole rat
[Music]
they can get by on just 33 the amount of
oxygen as other creatures their size
which may be one reason why naked mole
rats never age
unlike other animals its size which live
just a few years
naked mole rats are capable of scraping
out a life in the tunnels for over 30
years
that makes them the longest living
rodents in the world
[Music]
and not only are
they living that long time but they're
showing almost no signs of aging
in really long periods of drought where
they can't find food they can reduce
their metabolic intake up to 25
that's just so amazing
take a good look these wrinkles could be
the new face of eternal youth
but not only could they be the key to us
living longer
they may also help make that quality of
life better because they could help
eliminate pain
in people
naked mole rats lack a key
neurotransmitter in their skin called
substance p
it's what communicates pain to their
brain
it's believed to be an adaptation to
living underground where high amounts of
carbon dioxide would build up painful
acids in a normal mammal's body and so
there might be some really key medical
breakthroughs in in understanding pain
management
or developing new pain medicines based
on this
but as if all these abilities weren't
crazy enough
the naked mole rat takes it one step
further its most incredible adaptation
yet
they are completely resistant
to cancer
the naked mole rat has special molecules
that prevent cells from overcrowding
which may limit out-of-control cancer
growth
cancer has never been observed in a
naked mole rat and these are being
examined
to understand cancers better and
possibly be able to
prevent cancers or fight cancers in
humans
[Music]
so take time to appreciate the little
things out there
they may not always be pretty but they
may help
keep us alive
some say they can stay standing even
after they die
[Music]
they can strip the face off an antelope
with their tongues
they eat bears
all that
and some people believe there may be a
secret symbol hidden in their stripes
the tiger is next
[Music]
it has the strength of 13 men
and the most powerful bite of any cat
even its tongue
has teeth
some species weigh more than three sumo
wrestlers combined
and they all have special genes that
give them super strength
this is
the tiger
in siberia some bears have taken to
living in tree nests like frightened
birds
and it's all because of the biggest cat
on earth
you think of bears being the top of the
food chain
but not where there's tigers
tigers have been documented killing both
black bears and brown bears where they
coexist with them
but to get the upper paw on something as
tough as a bear
the tiger must be a mixture of both
stealth and size
cunning and execution
an animal in perfect balance
[Music]
to find out what makes the tiger such an
amazing predator we're taking a look at
some of its most impressive yins and
yangs beginning with this a tiger must
be the perfect balance of both power and
precision
[Music]
this is a gower
at up to 2 000 pounds it's like a cow on
steroids
according to some reports it takes more
than 13 full-grown men just to budge
this beast or
one tiger
i think that that really does highlight
just how incredibly powerful these
animals are in comparison to people
much stronger than 13 men
in fact a tiger's legs are so strong
it's said that they can stay standing
even after they die
in 2013 scientists looking into what
makes this big cat so powerful
did the first ever sequencing of a
tiger's
genome
what they found is that tigers have
specific genes that have evolved to
quickly turn the meat they eat into
stronger more powerful muscles
so that's the power but where's the
precision
huge four-inch canines bite with deadly
accuracy thanks to a surprising
mechanism hidden inside the teeth
the canines are packed with sensitive
nerve endings that actually feel like
fingers
they're called mechanoreceptors
and they allow the tiger's teeth to find
the perfect place for the quickest kill
within milliseconds they can perfectly
position those canines
to
deliver that sinking bite
this
is not a tiger
but it's not far off either
because even the fiercest tiger
is the perfect balance
of both kitten
and cat
tigers share about 95.6 of the same dna
as domestic cats
of course at up to 700 pounds the tiger
is no house cat
which is not to say some people don't
still try to own them
by some estimates there are between 5
000 and 7 000 tigers and other big cats
owned as pets in the united states alone
more than exist in the wild
outside of india the world's second
largest population of tigers is in texas
a lot of those tigers are in rescue
sanctuaries since most people come to
realize apex predators don't make great
pets
[Music]
in the sunderbins region of india the
people wear masks on the backs of their
heads
and it's not a fashion statement it's to
protect against tigers
before this practice human encroachment
into wild habitats led to around 100
humans being eaten every year
[Music]
since the big cats rely on the element
of surprise
creating the illusion of having eyes in
the back of your head has reduced the
number of attacks on mask wearers
down to zero
[Music]
but mask or no mask tiger attacks are
still extremely rare
because tiger moms raised their cubs
better than that using the perfect
balance
of nature and nurture
tigers certainly aren't born man-eaters
usually tigers will kill
and selectively kill the prey that their
mother teaches them to hunt and so you
know to pray switch to people is a big
jump and usually you have to be pretty
hard-pressed
but it is true that tigers need meat if
mom does her job right and her cub makes
it to adulthood it will need 6 000
pounds of biomass a year to survive
for a human that would be like eating
eight full porterhouse steaks every day
for a whole year
tigers are hyper carnivores so they get
absolutely no nutrition from anything
but meat
once a tiger does leave the nest it's
off to live a life of solitude or so
it's thought
while the general rule is that lions are
the only truly social cat newer research
suggests tigers might have more family
ties than previously believed
there was a tigress that was observed
her name was padmini she killed a very
large prey animal and she and her cubs
that were 14 months old sat for hours
eating this
large ungulate and after a while
three other individual tigers came by
and started sharing this meat
come to find out later on they were her
adult offspring that had come back for
for dinner essentially
it seems even full-grown tigers can't
resist
one of mom's home-killed meals
believe it or not what some people think
of as the saber-toothed tiger wasn't a
tiger at all can you guess which of
these replacement names we should be
calling this fanged beast
is it a a saber-toothed lion
b a saber-toothed possum
or c a saber-toothed pig
plus
the perfect balance of both sex
and violence
are there secret messages hidden in a
tiger stripes
some cultures believe so
to the chinese the lines on a tiger's
head look like the character wayne
meaning
king
but some of the earliest tigers weren't
tigers at all
[Music]
before the break we asked you what name
might be more fitting for what most
people know as the saber-tooth tiger
is it a a saber-toothed lion b a
saber-toothed possum or c a
saber-toothed fig
put away the cat food the answer is b
a saber-toothed possum
[Music]
there's different saber-toothed cats
what we truly think of of the
saber-tooth tiger was was actually a
marsupial
so it's related to animals like possums
today the tiger plays possum for no one
it is a perfect predator at the very top
of the food chain
but it takes a special mix to achieve
that status
including the perfect balance
of both light
and dark
tigers are the only wild cats with true
stripes and each tiger's stripes
are as unique as a fingerprint
software engineers have even designed a
program that uses photos of a tiger's
stripes
to create a 360 degree image
which can be used to automatically id an
individual tiger in the wild
the software can also help catch
poachers by identifying their illegal
furs
[Music]
but it's not just the tiger's fur that's
striped get brave enough to shave a
tiger
and you'll find that its skin is striped
too
the tiger's fur grows out of dark strips
of pigment called melanin creating the
pattern we see on the surface
[Music]
while having bright orange fur and bold
stripes might not seem like good
camouflage
this is where the balance of light and
dark really comes in
computer analysis shows that the stripes
of a tiger are finely tuned to match the
natural light and dark patterns of
background foliage
it's amazing how quickly those stripes
actually help that cat to melt into the
background and help break up its outline
it clearly has such an incredible role
in helping it to be an effective hunter
also helping the tiger be an effective
hunter
the perfect balance
of both slow and fast
the tiger kills with incredible speed
with the strongest bite of all the cats
it can clamp down on an animal's throat
suffocating it in seconds
from there it only gets deadlier
because even the tiger's tongue has
teeth
take a closer look
here we see little backward facing barbs
like mini fangs they're called papilla
and they're perfectly designed to strip
the fur off meat
but before the tiger can make short work
of its meal
it must be one of the most patient
predators on earth
first they find the perfect ambush spot
and they will go time and time again to
that same area to hunt
then like a cobra ready to strike
it can hold this position according to
some accounts for anywhere between 12
and 48 hours every single muscle is
ready to just explode
i mean just the sheer amount of strength
that that tiger has to have to be able
to do that is is incredible anyone that
does yoga you know i mean you hold that
pose for a few minutes i mean your
muscles are burning
in fact according to one website the
current public record for the longest
time a human has held a dancer's pose is
just six minutes and 52 seconds
that's holding a pose 47 hours and 53
minutes less than a tiger
it takes a lot of space to accommodate a
cat this big
a single siberian tiger needs as much as
600 square miles worth of resources it's
almost half the size of the state of
rhode island just to kind of put that in
perspective
that need for so much personal space is
one of the reasons we don't usually see
tigers hanging out in prides like lions
but staying apart is no way to keep the
species going so when it comes to
procreation
tigers maintain the perfect balance of
sex and violence
[Music]
tigers are basically so solitary that
the males and females generally it's
only mating when they come across each
other
females want nothing to do with males
most of the time but all of her hormones
just kind of overrule her her wanting to
be solitary for a few day window
during that window the female will spray
little pheromone laced forget-me-nots
wherever she roams
letting males know she's receptive
male tigers can follow a female scent
trail for miles up to 18 miles in one
night
that's like walking up and down pikes
peak in colorado
nearly four times in 12 hours
just for the possibility of a date
[Music]
but once two tigers finally find each
other it's all worth it
[Music]
he will mate with her
multiple times
every day for several days in a row
and so they'll stay together they may
hunt together they might feed together
they'll pretty much do everything
together
until she's no longer receptive anymore
and then all of a sudden you know she
just will turn around and she'll
swat him in the face
then that's it and then he has to get
out of there
no call you later or even a thanks for
the good time just one very painful walk
of shame
it's got both the power
and the patience
secret stripes
i hate seeking teeth
but is this apex predator tough enough
to take on another larger-than-life
champion one of the most highly skilled
athletes of all time
tiger woods
an epic battle of undisputed champions
next
the tiger really is a perfectly balanced
creature right down to its bones
its hind legs are longer than the front
which helps propel the tiger up to 10
feet high
at the same time its solid four limb
bones support large muscles allowing
them to wrestle big prey to the ground
but as flawless as the tiger seems to be
there is another perfectly balanced
competitor out there
one with a peak body and skills to give
the tiger a run for its money it's tiger
versus tiger
tiger woods weighs about 185 pounds and
stands tall at six foot one
an average siberian tiger weighs between
400 and 700 pounds and stretched out end
to end would stand up to 11 feet tall so
that's advantage tiger
a tiger can also see six times better in
the dark than tiger woods
so it would probably win any night
tournaments
but now the competition really heats up
let's take it to the lakes
wrong links
when tiger woods hits the ball his club
reaches a top speed of 130 miles per
hour when a tiger hits its prey it's at
less than 40 miles per hour
advantage woods
tiger woods can drive a ball nearly 400
yards a tiger
that's like what a foot
tiger woods has won 26 of all pga events
he's ever entered
has a driving accuracy of 46.4
and can sink a putt from six feet or
closer with an amazing 100 accuracy a
real tiger only catches prey one out of
every 10 hunts an accuracy rate of just
10
it's not looking good for the tiger
especially since with all of his
achievements tiger woods was number one
in the world for an incredible 683 weeks
but hold up
because the actual tiger has been the
number one predator in its environment
for over 2 million years
so according to the laws of nature
unless tiger woods uncovers the fountain
of youth the tiger is and always will be
the most perfectly balanced champion in
the land
disclaimer never play golf for the tiger
according to the internet it's illegal
for two pigs in kingsville texas
to fornicate on airport property that's
unfortunate because i really was hoping
to do my peak population study right
here in terminal three that's not cool
our sources haven't confirmed if that
law is true but there are plenty of
actual animal laws in the books
some of them just make sense
these
these are not those laws
[Music]
in oklahoma it is illegal to wrestle
bears
or trip horses
in arizona you can do a lot of things
with your donkey
but be careful putting it to bed
because here donkeys are prohibited from
sleeping in bathtubs
farther up north
in what many consider to be the last
frontier
locals don't have to worry about falling
ungulates thankfully in alaska it is
illegal to push a moose out of an
airplane
[Music]
that is the weirdest law
[Music]
in california it is illegal to trap
birds in a cemetery
and on the other side of the country in
connecticut there's a law that states
dogs cannot have tattoos
i i don't know what to tell you
i can tell you that they just passed the
law that
mexican wolves are not allowed to cross
the i-40
i don't know who's gonna stand there
with a sign telling the wolves not to
cross but that's like
in the state of virginia on sundays it
is illegal to hunt raccoons until 2 a.m
it's at 2 a.m monday morning or
saturday night
in the city that houses the pro football
hall of fame canton ohio
if you lose your pet tiger they'll flag
you with a penalty if you don't notify
the authorities in one hour
an hour
you have an hour to report your
man-eater to the authorities an hour a
lot can be killed in an hour ohio
so remember
the next time you're hanging out with
animals
keep it legal
[Music]
[Music]
you